[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily the
immediate cause of death is gunshot
wound of the chest and we've listed here
deceiving was shot by another person and
in parentheses law enforcement officer
gripping testimony in minnesota as the
trial for ex-cop kim potter moves into
week two and the federal sex crimes
trial of gillane maxwell we break down
the prosecution's case before the
defense calls its first witness plus the
defense rests its case and closing
arguments are on the way in the trial of
former ceo elizabeth holmes and the
murdoch murder mystery takes another
turn as the disbarred attorney's bond is
set for seven million dollars law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the start of week two kicks off
with expert testimony in the trial of
minnesota versus kim potter on monday
the jury heard from a forensic scientist
and the medical examiner who told jurors
the results of dante wright's autopsy
and now dr dr jackson based on your
training and experience did you
ultimately determine a cause of death
for for dante right in this case yes and
what was the cause of death the cause of
death in this case was gunshot wound of
the chest
and did you also determine a manner of
death for dante rape yes this is
certified as a homicide
and what is the definition of homicide
with respect to your work
homicide is death at the hands of
another
and how did you make the determination
that dante wright died by homicide
the examination of the wound
and
the history provided supported
that he was shot by another individual
potter an ex-minnesota police officer
faces first and second-degree
manslaughter charges in the death of
20-year-old wright on april 11 wright
was pulled over at a traffic stop in
brooklyn center minnesota just outside
the twin cities at the time wright told
his mom he was being pulled over for an
air freshener hanging in his rearview
mirror officers say he was pulled over
for unregistered tags officers then
attempted to take right into custody for
an arrest warrant body camera footage
shows a struggle between wright and the
officers potter then shot right in the
chest he died as a result of the
injuries potter maintains she
accidentally grabbed her gun instead of
a taser on monday jurors were shown the
gun and the round involved in the
shooting
this is
officer potter's firearm and they the
loose cartridge that's in the box as
well as the magazine that was loaded
okay is this the live round which is
taken from the chamber of the firearm
yes it is
i see officer potter's firearm it is a
glock nine millimeter semi-automatic
pistol in the magazine what is shown on
this part of the exhibit
um this is the
cartridge that was said to be taken out
of the chamber of the gun
the jury also saw body camera and squad
camera footage of the shooting from
multiple angles
[Music]
i just shot him
[Music]
oh my okay
a use of force investigator explained
the key takeaways from the body cam
footage
it appeared to me
in watching this that there was a
manipulation in some way of
her holster
why did that attract your attention
um i've seen it before
on other videos i've watched of officers
i myself
have done that when i was uh on patrol
um
just caught my attention
yep and what when you're on patrol what
what exactly are you believing that your
is occurring on the video um
so i
i carried us uh the same type of holster
that officer potter used level two
and
it would be my practice at times to when
i was making a traffic stop
unlatch
the first
level of
protection or safety on the
holster
um just
to i guess give myself a little of an
advantage should i need to draw
okay
so essentially it's a way to if you had
to draw your firearm
you're preparing to do it more quickly
yes why would you why would you do that
um it it would just make
drawing the firearm
easier
more efficient okay
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and terry
austin bernard during sergeant
peterson's testimony the prosecution
wanted to but could not let the jury
touch the taser uh did that make any
sense to you
so i have mixed emotions as to whether
the jury would have been allowed to
touch the taser you know brian from
doing trials that of course any evidence
even if it's physical evidence can be
shown to the jury and if the judge
approves of it it can also be touched by
the jury so what judge two did in this
case is that even though she said they
couldn't judge it she reserved decision
as to whether doing closing arguments or
at a later time whether the jury can
touch it it may end up that she doesn't
want to put them in a position that
she's making them witnesses to the crime
by touching the taser and them forming
their own opinions of whether it could
have been mistaken for a gun yeah it's
interesting because the touch and the
feeling of the gun is such a big part of
this case terry the defense made a lot
of objections some were sustained some
were overruled what did you think of the
defense's objections and the judge's
rulings
you know earl grey the defense attorney
or one of them made so many objections
to leading questions which basically
brian were harmless error to minor
points he could have let them go
especially when you can rephrase it he
objected to lack of foundation he
objected to having testimony that was
beyond cross he objected to everything
and i think that the judge
really basically sustained many of his
objections and you know she made
decisions i think that were haphazard
sometimes she made a good decision and
sometimes she didn't but basically i
think earl grey is possibly going to get
on the nerves of the jury we'll see how
that plays out as his case continues
also in minnesota former police officer
derek chovin is expected to plead guilty
to federal charges in the death of
george floyd shown faces charges of
deprivation of rights under color of law
in floyd's death he had pled not guilty
now a hearing has been set for wednesday
where shogun will change his plea chopin
is also charged with violating a
teenager's civil rights during an arrest
but that case appears to be moving
forward the former police officer is
currently serving a 22 and a half year
sentence after being found guilty in
state court of second and third degree
murder and second degree manslaughter in
floyd's death earlier this year
a texas judge will soon rule on a change
of venue request for a former fort worth
police officer accused in the 2019
shooting death of a black woman
aaron dean's attorneys claim the
extensive news coverage in tarrant
county will make it impossible to find a
fair trial in october 2019 dean
responded to a 9-1-1 welfare call after
reports that someone's front door was
open attatiana jefferson grabbed a gun
from her purse when she heard dean and
another officer walking through her
backyard dean then fired one shot
through the window that hit jefferson
she died as a result of her injuries at
the time of the shooting jefferson was
babysitting her nephew a judge is
expected to make a ruling on the change
of venue motion at a second hearing set
for tuesday if convicted dean could face
a sentence of life in prison jury
selection is scheduled to begin january
4th and as now as of now the trial will
begin the 10th
still ahead on law and crime daily
closing arguments are set to begin after
weeks of testimony as former theron's
ceo elizabeth holm faces a possible 20
years behind bars
but first the defense will soon make its
case after weeks of testimony and dozens
of witnesses in geelane maxwell's sex
crimes trial we zero in on the
prosecution's case and was to be
expected from the other side
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back the government rests his
case in the elaine maxwell criminal sex
trafficking trial this after two weeks
of emotional testimony from 24 witnesses
59-year-old maxwell faces sex crime
charges stemming from her relationship
with former financier jeffrey epstein
maxwell is accused of helping epstein
groom teenage girls for sexual abuse
epstein maxwell's longtime companion was
indicted in july 2019 on similar charges
but died by suicide in prison a month
later four of maxwell's accusers
testified for the prosecution detailing
alleged sexual abuse by maxwell and
epstein during cross-examination the
defense scored favorable rulings from
the judge who said two of the four women
were old enough to consent at the time
the alleged encounters the jury also
heard from employees who worked at
epstein's properties and his former
pilots the defense is expected to start
its case thursday
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney bernard velona and terry austin
to look back on the prosecution's case
against maxwell and ahead to hers
terry promises of advancing their
careers in education grooming and a
little black book how did the
prosecution build a case around these
pillars
those were two very important pillars
brian the grooming all four of the
witnesses testified about the grooming
they said that they were promised they
were going to get an advance in their
career they were promised they were
going to get educational opportunities
and they were selected when they were at
their most vulnerable so i believe that
the grooming was really testified about
and proven by the prosecution the other
thing about the little black book is we
had the house manager testify about that
little black book he said there were
hundreds and hundreds of names in that
book and he stated that they were
definitely entered by maxwell so i think
that they've established also that
maxwell was involved in booking these
massages yeah now bernardo the defense
is expected to put on a massive case
with more witnesses than the prosecution
what should be expecting in their case
yeah so the defense on thursday begins
their defense and in the defense they
are stating that they're going to call
35 witnesses or 11 more witnesses than
the prosecution called but the defense
is going to bring it back to what their
opening statement was and their opening
statement their theme was money
manipulation money and manipulation that
and memories and that's what they're
going to bring it back to especially
they're looking to call an expert to
testify how memories fade and how it can
affect the testimony it has affected the
testimony of the alleged victims in this
case so that's what we expect to see a
lot of expert testimony in terms of
memories and then the other witnesses
let's just call it fluff we'll see how
this plays out as we continue with that
federal trial of course we don't have
cameras in there because of federal law
which we can show you more but you of
course continue to follow law and crime
daily for your update on this case
switching gears now to arkansas where a
second at 19 kids and counting reality
star faces charges jaina duggar is
charged with endangering a minor this
comes just days after her brother josh
duggar is convicted of possessing child
pornography the 31 year old pled not
guilty to the misdemeanor that allegedly
occurred in early september details of
the case are closed off from the public
for the sake of protecting the minor
involved there is no evidence that jaina
duggar and her brother's case are
connected if convicted duggar faces up
to three months behind bars and up to a
thousand dollar fine duggar is set to
appear in court on january 10th
coming up on law on crime daily a seven
million dollar bond is set for disgraced
one-time attorney alec murdoch we break
down his latest charges
plus the founder and former ceo of blood
testing company theranos finishes out
her days-long testimony as the defense
rests its case what could come next for
elizabeth holmes find out when we come
back
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
defense rests in federal court in
california after 11 weeks of testimony
in elizabeth holmes fraud trial
holmes is the founder and former ceo of
theranos a silicon valley lab touted to
be a breakthrough blood testing company
holmes claimed her technology was faster
and cheaper than traditional blood
testing but later tess found many issues
with holmes edison's device while on the
stand holmes claimed she was the victim
of a decade-long abusive relationship
with ramesh sunny bhawani the company's
coo she told the jury she tried to
control nearly every aspect of her life
holmes testified she wasn't aware of
everything going on at their nose and
that she never tried to mislead
investors or patients she ended her
testimony by telling jurors her pitch to
their knows investors was about quote
what we created and what was possible
holmes was the third and final witness
called by the defense the government did
not put on a rebuttal case she faces up
to 20 years in prison and a quarter
million dollar fine plus restitution
closing arguments are set for thursday
now both sides in the elizabeth homeless
trial have now rested with summations to
begin december 17. so let's have
criminal defense attorney bernard
bernardo velona and co-host terry austin
break down what will be expected from
each summation terry let's start with
the prosecution what should we expect
there
well they're going to have to put
together their entire story they had 29
witnesses that's a lot of people to talk
about they have to show that she
deliberately deceived her investors her
patients and the doctors and that she
took the money to advance her career she
admitted on the stand and they're going
to have to say this that the buck stops
with her she also admitted that the
machines that she used were not her
machines because her machines were
failing she also said that they only
performed 12 tests on their own devices
that's not enough test to say that the
machines were working properly and she
even admitted brian that the
pharmaceutical logos that were put on
the reports were personally put on by
her so if the prosecution can say all of
that i think they're going to be able to
tell the story to the jury for a
conviction all right bernard let's check
out the other side now what's the
defense going to have to present on the
summation
so elizabeth holmes you know she
testified for seven days so what
elizabeth holmes is going to focus on
the defense attorney for elizabeth
holmes is that look this is just a
failed startup this is some invention
that she tried to bring up but there was
no intention to deceive it that she was
being physically and emotionally and
mentally abused by this man who had all
the control over the company and
everything that was being put out there
and because of that there is no
intention to deceive and you can believe
her and reasonable doubt has been
created so to find her not guilty all
right those are the arguments on both
sides as we said on thursday that's what
likely we'll be hearing and of course
when we get those closing arguments and
we potentially get a verdict we'll be
here on law and crime daily to bring
them to you
when we come back the murdoch murder
mystery the latest twists and turns in
the case as the disgraced south carolina
attorney addresses a judge in monday's
virtual court hearing all that and more
after this
welcome back we look to florida now for
an update on the man responsible for one
of the deadliest school shootings in u.s
history nicholas cruz a judge rules the
death penalty is still on the table in
october cruz pled guilty to the parkland
school shooting where 17 people were
killed and 17 more injured on
valentine's day 2018. cruz and his
defense team requested to remove the
death penalty from consideration but a
florida judge has denied those requests
victim impact statements have also taken
center stage in this case cruz's defense
attorney says hearing victim impact
statements could cause too many emotions
for the jury to make a sound decision
judge elizabeth overruled the request at
her hearing on monday the defense
attorney requested victim impact
statements instead be read by a third
party
having a neutral priority read any
victim impact statements will minimize
the potential for the emotional nature
of these statements to improperly
influence the jury because a neutral
party will be capable of maintaining
appropriate deform so as not to unfairly
and unconstitutionally inflame the
emotions of the jury and prejudice mr
cruz and they were right to be heard
and they have right to voice their
feelings about the uniqueness of the
victims in this case as it relates to
the impact of the loss of the victims
to their lives
it is not
aggravate it is not an aggravation of
the defendant's sentence it is merely
other evidence
there is no reason that this evidence
should be deluded
because the defendant has asked it to be
deluded the motion should be denied your
honor okay respectfully 43 is denied
judge traitor ruled victim impact
statements will not be read by a third
party jury selection is scheduled to
begin january 4th for cruz's sentencing
the jury will decide whether crews
should receive the death penalty as a
sentence
switching to south carolina now where
embattled lawyer alec murdoch is now
accused of stealing more than six
million dollars from clients and his
former law firm some of the charges
murdoch faces are related to more than 4
million in life insurance money for his
housekeeper who died in 2018. murdoch
was already facing charges after
officials say he tried to arrange his
own murder so his only living son would
get a 10 million insurance payout during
a bond hearing on the new financial
charges murdoch said that he's
embarrassed and wants to repair the
damage he's done the judge set murdoch's
bail at 7 million
his attorneys call that essentially no
bail at all another judge had previously
denied bail to murdoch calling him a
danger to himself and others murdoch is
a person of interest in the murders of
his wife maggie and son paul he has
denied involvement
bernard murdoch is accused of defrauding
over 6.2 million dollars in total what
criminal civil and professional
repercussions is he facing
brian he's facing all of the above i
choose answer e and this alex murdoch
has so much going on aside from the
criminal case that he has now these
potential charges coming up now as well
as remember they're still looking into
him for any homicide charges having to
deal with any of the numerous deaths
that have already been mentioned
regarding his housekeeper as well as
family members in this case so i'm
curious to see just waiting to see
what's going to come from this
now terry can you explain the bond and
release conditions were they too strict
not enough or just right in your eyes
i think those restrictions were just
right i mean they're strict but they're
appropriate he can probably maybe raise
the bond but if he is there are some
restrictions so he has to be monitored
with the gps he has to remain under
house arrest he has to surrender his
passport and if he leaves the state he
has to waive extradition and importantly
he has to get substance abuse counseling
now all of this might seem like a lot to
anyone else who doesn't know the
background of this case but like bernard
said he's accused of so many different
things and he himself even said he
understood people's concerns and he made
bad decisions and he was at a different
place he regrets those decisions so i
think that all of the bond restrictions
make sense all right we'll see if he
does in fact bail out uh but thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you